influenza or the flu is a contagious
viral infection that attacks your nose
throat
and lungs
it can cause fever
chills runny nose sore throat
cough muscle aches and fatigue the flu
virus is extremely small and only
visible through electron microscopes
inside the virus genetic material
contains the information to make more
copies of the same virus a protein shell
provides a hard protective enclosure for
the genetic material as the virus
travels between the people or animals it
infects an outer envelope allows the
virus to infect cells by merging with
the cell's outer membrane projecting
from the envelope are spikes of protein
molecules the flu virus uses its h
spikes like a key to get inside your
cells n spikes allow copies of the virus
to break away from your infected cells
to infect more cells there are 17 known
types of H spikes and nine types of n
spikes that scientists use to name
different flu viruses such as the virus
h5n1 you get the flu by touching an
object that has the flu virus on it or
through exposure to body fluids from
people or animals infected with the
virus when an infected person talks
coughs or sneezes droplets carrying the
influenza virus may land in your mouth
or nose and then move into your lungs
once inside your body
the influenza virus comes into contact
with cells in your nose throat or lungs
the H spike on the virus insert into a
receptor molecule on your healthy cell
membrane like a key in a lock
this action allows the virus to get
inside your cell
next the virus travels inside a sack
made from your cell membrane to your
cells nucleus
then the viral envelope and cell
membrane sack combined allowing the
viral genetic material to leave the sack
and enter the nucleus
the viral genetic material hijacks the
energy and materials in your cell's
nucleus to make thousands of copies of
itself some of the genetic material
moves out of the nucleus then attaches
to ribosomes which are the protein
building parts of your cell ribosomes
use information from the genetic
material to make other viral proteins
such as the h and n spikes a packaging
structure in your cell called the Golgi
apparatus carries the h and n spikes in
vesicles which merge with your cell's
membrane all the parts needed to create
a new virus gather just beneath your
cell's membrane
then a new virus begins to butt off from
the cell's membrane during this process
the newly created virus gets stuck on
your cell's membrane when a viral h
spike locks on to membrane receptors
however the virus has a way to get
around this problem
the viral end spike frees the virus by
cutting it away from the receptor new
influenza viruses are now free to infect
more of your cells and cause you to
develop the flu
if you have the flu your doctor may
prescribe oseltamivir which you would
take orally or zanamivir which you would
take using an inhaler to help speed your
recovery or reduce your risk for
complications
these antiviral drugs stop the influenza
virus by blocking the viral and spike
from freeing the virus
this causes the new viruses to stick to
the surface of your cell so they cannot
escape and infect more of your cells
the best way to protect yourself from
the flu is to get the flu vaccine every
year you may receive the vaccine as a
shot which contains dead versions of
several types of the virus or you may
receive it as a nasal spray which
contains several types of live but very
weak forms of the virus the vaccine
exposes your body to several types of
the influenza virus that are too weak to
cause infection but just strong enough
to stimulate an immune response within
two weeks cells in your immune system
make markers called antibodies which are
specific for only the types of flu you
were exposed to the antibodies attach to
each flu virus and prevent it from
attaching to your cells antibodies are
also able to attach to more than one flu
virus which causes viruses to clump
together your immune system responds to
signals from the antibodies by engulfing
and destroying the clumps of viruses
later if you are exposed to these types
of flu again your body recognizes and
destroys them so you will not develop
the flu from these same viruses for
continued protection against new flu
viruses you will need to get a flu
vaccine every year